little thing I thought if we have
Ocean's eleven twelve and thirteen to
make trilogy out of this new one we'll
have oceans eight nine and ten which
means we'll have oceans eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen it's kind of
clever oceans eight the oceans eight is
not a remake of Ocean's eleven which was
a remake of Ocean's eleven oceans it's
actually a sequel or a spin-off takes
place in the same universe takes place
after ocean's 13 Sandra Bullock plays
the sister of George Clooney's character
from Ocean's eleven who is Daniel ocean
she's the new ocean she's gonna get a
team together and they're gonna pull off
a heist so they're gonna steal they're
gonna steal a diamond necklace from a
fashion show and for the most part the
general crew in this movie they did a
fine job
I did like Cate Blanchett the most
actually I liked Rihanna - I mean she
has very few lines in the movie I just
generally liked her personality she's a
pothead hacker who doesn't like that
which goes to show you you can be a
standout character and not have the most
line so perhaps to her that she did that
at least for me I should I really liked
an Hathaway - and Heather weighs the one
they're essentially going to steal from
but Anne Hathaway just as an actress is
so good at playing someone who's really
likable and also someone who's got a
fool himself acting they would come up
but you see what I mean by the crew did
a good job didn't always have good
things to work with but for what they
had they did good for their part however
there are a little hamstrung
technology's just evolved for a lot of
it Rihanna's like I'm gonna be the one
solving the problem pushed a button on
my laptop all I gotta push for you it's
getting a little intense but he's fixed
now so it takes away from a lot of the
banter the trial and error the scope of
the situation so really for a lot of
this movie you're seeing his crew hang
out and talk which would be really cool
if I was as interested if I was as
invested wouldn't the Banshees going
back and forth between Cate Blanchett
and Sandra Bullock a couple of times
like alright let's move it along I tried
to project George Clooney and Brad Pitt
into their situations and I was like
nope if it were George Clooney and Brad
Pitt I'd still find this kind of boring
I still feel like I was watching Ocean's
Twelve instead if it was a hard dialogue
about the heist so you can see the plan
start to grow so you start to take form
take shape
I enjoyed that it was anything else
where they were talking I started to
check out sometimes I was like I feel
like we're killing time and that's where
I feel like a better script would have
played well for this I've used his name
a few times that I know his scripts the
dialogue essentially just sounds like
the same thing over and over and over
again but I really do feel like Aaron
Sorkin for this script or an Aaron
Sorkin style of writing worked
really well for the characters in the
situation just didn't feel as engaging
as it could have been given the
actresses you have delivering the lines
when the heist is going down it picks up
and it is really slack I like the
execution as it was happening but this
might be a personal preference for me
rather than a critique but I just feel
like the job itself was a little
lackluster there stealing a diamond
necklace granted a diamond necklace is a
time-honored tradition among Hollywood
movies and I feel like it's also very
outdated but if I'm just looking at the
job in this movie the jobs just not that
interesting there we go a big part of
the brick and mortar in this movie not
that interesting so in the end oceans 8
I thought was a great idea and sometimes
the execution looks like it was working
sometimes it dragged on a little bit I
did like the crew I thought the crew did
a good job in the movie oh really I just
I don't even know if it's this movie I
feel like I've seen it all when it comes
to highest films I feel like a Vegas
vault is the end-all be-all cap of
ripping anyone on at that point you got
to make it super personal to rip off
artifacts which has happened or art
which has happened in the end I would
say oceans a it's probably a better time
if you're drunk ya know it's a birdie
bristle ocean's 8 have you seen it what
did you think about it or what's the
order of the oceans movies that you like
from best to worst whatever they're
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]